Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Was ist los in der Premier League? Wir wollen mal wieder auf eine europäische Top-Liga schauen und beginnen hier in diesem 93. Kurzpass mit einem Blick nach England zusammen mit Uli Hebel von DAZN. Uli, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt. Hi. Ach, das ist schön. Das freut mich. Und die Hörerinnen und Hörer haben sich definitiv dieses Lob verdient. Wir wollen heute auf die Premier League schauen. Da sind jetzt drei Spieltage gespielt. Der vierte steht an. Und wenn ich mir einfach mal, Uli, die Tabelle so angucke, dann sehe ich da einige Teams, nämlich genau sieben, die noch nicht verloren haben nach drei Spieltagen. Ganz viele davon überraschen mich nicht. Also Liverpool, Tottenham, Chelsea, City hätte man mit rechnen können. Aber bei zwei beziehungsweise drei Teams möchte ich jetzt mal kurz die Rückfrage stellen. Aktuell auf Platz 4 und mit drei Siegen nach drei Spieltagen der FC Wattford. Was ist denn da los?
Wenn ich es wüsste. Ich habe den Tipp abgegeben, dass Ravi Grazia der erste Trainer ist, der den Hut nehmen muss. Das liegt zum einen daran, dass die Inhaberfamilie Pozzo zu Verrücktheiten neigt, wenn es nicht ganz so gut läuft. Und zum anderen liegt es daran, dass ich gedacht habe, dass es nicht ganz so gut laufen wird. Die haben sich jetzt nicht großartig verstärkt, im Gegenteil, haben einfach nur den Kader beisammengehalten. Die hatten ein paar Verletzungsprobleme, die sind jetzt erstmal weg. Haben aber jetzt einen guten Torwart drin und haben eine gute Taktik von Grazia bekommen, der da wohl über dem Sommer fast Defensives erarbeitet hat. Und sind schwer zu überwinden und das reicht dann auch schon. Haben wir letztes Jahr auch, da war Stoukoure. Und vorletztes Jahr war es Kapu wieder, einen, der ganz gut drauf ist, in Roberto Pereira, der schon drei Tore gemacht hat. Aber kurzum, trotz eines vergleichsweise leichten Programms, das hätte ich im Leben nicht geglaubt, dass die drei Siege haben. Aber für mich, also vielleicht werde ich da eines besseren belehrt, aber für mich erst mal drei Siege für den Klassenerhalt. Das klingt vielleicht ein bisschen komisch, aber so würde ich es trotzdem erstmal sehen.
Okay, wir werden jetzt dann den Lackmustest haben. Am vierten Spieltag, jetzt am Sonntag spielen sie zu Hause gegen Tottenham und dann zu Hause gegen United. Ich würde sagen, dann können wir ein bisschen mehr über die wahre Leistungsfähigkeit von Watford sagen. Was kannst du mir denn zum AFC Bournemouth erzählen, der ist ja auch noch ungeschlagen bei einem Unentschieden und zwei Siegen?
Ja, das ist im Grunde relativ ähnlich. Also die haben sich einmal wieder clever verstärkt mit Lärmer und ansonsten haben die einfach nur den Teil zusammengehalten. Auch da Auftragsprogramm dankbar, würde ich mal sagen. Trotzdem gab es ein paar Spiele, wo es auch wirklich hätte anders laufen können. Vor allen Dingen am 1. Spiele gegen Cardiff. Alles in allem, aber die gehen weiterhin ihren Weg. Eddie Howe ist da schon seit Ewigkeiten. Zumindest aktuelle Fußball-Verhältnisse seit Ewigkeiten. Ich glaube, 2012 ist das Datum irgendwann. Ich glaube, Oktober hat er übernommen und zieht halt die ganze Zeit seine Idee durch. Auch der hat ein bisschen Glück, dass jetzt da Leute sind, die endlich mal gesund geblieben sind. Und wird sich auch noch korrigieren, aber nicht so drastisch, wie ich das bei Watford habe. Also ich glaube, Bournemouth kann schon, wenn es ganz gut geht, so Burnley 2018, 2019 werden.
Und sag mal, wenn du jetzt sagst, Eddie Hau voll durch richtig natürlich schon seit 2012 da, der ist ja erst 40 Jahre alt. Wie lief denn das damals, dass der im Alter von 32 Jahren ja dann Bournemouth-Trainer wurde?
Er hat sich recht früh, recht schwer verletzt und ging dann in eine Mannschaft Bournemouths, die so gut wie Pleite war. Und hat sich dann auch noch mal ganz kurz verändert sogar. Er hat versucht, was anderes zu machen, ist aber dann wieder zurückgekehrt. Also ist schon seine zweite Amtszeit, wenn man die aufaddieren würde, wäre er noch länger im Amt. Da hat er sich wirklich mal versucht, für nicht mal ein ganzes Jahr zu verändern. Und hat auch in dieser Zeit noch mal wahnsinnig viel gelernt, was Offensivfußball betrifft. Das ist nämlich das Schöne daran, der mauert nicht. Also das ist der große Unterschied zu Burnley. Ich möchte ihm gar nicht zu nahe treten, Sean Dash macht da einen riesen Job. Aber die Hausspielweise ist die wesentlich attraktivere. Es sieht immer so ein bisschen aus, als wäre das eine graue Maus. Mir geht es ehrlich gesagt auch oft so, wenn ich im Dienstplan sehe, Bournemouth ist schon seit vier Jahren die gleiche Mannschaft. Und jedes Mal, wenn ich mir dann auch nur die Statistiken in der Vorbereitung zugemütete führe, spätestens dann aber wenn ich die wirklich kommentiere, denke ich mir jedes Mal, ah, schöne Truppe eigentlich.
Ach genau, deswegen liebe ich diese Kurzpässe mit dir. So, das war mir alles nicht bewusst mit Eddie Howe, habe ich jetzt erst quasi durch dich erfahren. So soll das sein im Kurzpass. Und wir haben noch eine weitere Mannschaft, die ungeschlagen ist, da konnte man so halb mitrechnen. Der FC Everton mit zwei Unentschieden, einem Sieg. Damit ja gut, jetzt zeitweise mal auf Platz 8. Aber generell hatte ich auch den Eindruck, Everton war so mit eins der größten Gesprächsthemen im Sommer. Deswegen wollte ich da jetzt mal kurz bei dir nachfragen, wie ist da der Stand? Sind die zufrieden mit ihrem Start?
Es geht so. Also Everton ist ja traditionell ein recht ruhiger Club. Das heißt, auch wenn sich das jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren ein bisschen verändert hat, die sind schon recht genügsam. Die haben jetzt endlich ihren Wunschtrainer bekommen, den sie eigentlich schon, so gesehen war es ein verlorenes Jahr, das letzte, auch schon in der Vorsaison, ganz gerne wohl gehabt hätten. Also gab ja die Geschichte, dass sie da bis zu 5 Millionen geboten haben sollen an Wattford, um den nach Ronald Koeman installieren zu dürfen. Da hat Wattford seinerzeit nein gesagt, um ihn zwei Monate später zu entlassen. Und Everton war aber halt schon bei Sam Allardyce im Watt und der hat ja auch einen ordentlichen Job gemacht. Aber wie das halt so ist mit dieser Art von Manager, der bringt die Mannschaft jetzt erstmal nicht weiter, sondern der hält sie einfach nur drin und das hat er gut gemacht. So gesehen will ich jetzt da gar nicht irgendwie zu negativ sein. Aber jetzt haben sie Markus Silber und du merkst schon ein ganz anderer Ansatz vom Fußballspiel. Und das Problem, und da bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt drauf, Markus Silber hat in all seinen, also es waren nur zwei englischen Stationen, in der ersten Hälfte seiner Amtszeit gute Ergebnisse geholt und guten Fußball zeigen lassen. Und danach wurde es ein bisschen schwächer. Und ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt, wie das bei Everton aussieht. Geld ist da, die Mannschaft ist gut verstärkt, bis sehr gut verstärkt sogar. Also André Gomes, bin ich mal gespannt, mal gucken, wie das wird. Aber sowas wie beispielsweise Richa Lison oder Lucas Dinier, das sind starke Verpflichtungen.
Ich finde auch Mina von Barca sehr interessant.
Jari Mina, ja, richtig. Und du hast Kurt Zuma in der Innenverteidigung beispielsweise geholt, das vergessen ganz viele, den vergessen sowieso viele, weil der einfach in dieser französischen Innenverteidigungskonzentration fast untergeht. Also das ist ein Klassikkader. Du hast einen, was die Altersstruktur betrifft, super interessanten Kader. Du hast einen breiten Kader und die sind nicht weit weg von den Top 6. Und wenn es blöd läuft für den ein oder anderen Verein, über den wir auch noch sprechen werden, dann könnte Everton vielleicht sogar auf die 6 rutschen. Und dann spielst du bei Arsenal plötzlich nicht mal mehr Europa League, wenn es ganz drum läuft. Also ich habe insgesamt eine gute Prognose für Everton. Die hatte ich ehrlich gesagt auch schon letzte Saison. In der Vorbereitung dachte ich, manch, das sieht gut aus. Und habe auch gedacht, mit Sigurdson könnte vielleicht so der Spieler jetzt da sein, der alles ganz gut macht. Ich habe dann aber im Nachhinein auch in der Selbstreflexion gemerkt, nee, eigentlich hätte mir mal auffallen müssen, dass da ein bisschen Tempo über die Außen fehlt. Und dass das logischerweise so gar nicht werden kann. Noch dazu mit diesem antizipierten Spielsystem unter Kummern. Das ist ja dann auch recht schnell eingerissen worden. Aber das System Silver passt ganz gut zum Material, denke ich. Und an vielen Baustellen ist da gearbeitet worden. Also da haben sie wirklich so die Lücken schließen können. Also meine Prognose ist ganz okay für Everton. Wäre jetzt auch nicht schlimm, wenn sie nur Zehnther werden. Ich hoffe halt, dass sie dann Silver erst mal weiterarbeiten lassen. Und dann kann das so in zwei bis drei Jahren wirklich konstant Top 6 gehen. Und wenn er ernst macht und das droht da an, dann sind da Leute wie Abramowicz sogar Schuljungs dagegen.
Ach ja, Wahnsinn, die Investoren in der Premier League. Also fast 100 Millionen Euro hat man investiert, noch ein bisschen Einnahmen generiert durch Transfers. Transfersaito, irgendwas um die 75 Millionen. Das ist nicht die Spitze in der Premier League, aber schon ein sehr ordentliches Investment. Wenn du jetzt schon ansprichst, dass es ja auch Mannschaften gibt, die gerade ein bisschen kriseln nach diesem dritten Spieltag, dann müssen wir vor allem jetzt mal über Manchester United sprechen. Denn da hat man von der Krise natürlich auch mal wieder etwas mitbekommen, weil José Mourinho nach der 0-3-Heimniederlage gegen die Spurs eine, ja, doch wieder recht denkwürdig, Pressekonferenz gegeben hat, in denen er noch mal kurz seine drei Premier League-Titel gegen die zwei gewonnenen Titel aller anderen Trainer der Liga aufgerechnet hat, ein bisschen mehr Respekt gefordert hat und dann hat er die Pressekonferenz verlassen. Ist das denn auch Zeichen einer wirklich tiefergehenden Krise oder erliegen wir da wieder so einem Mourinho-Ablenkungsmanöver, dass niemand über die Mannschaft spricht und alle über ihn?
Na, ich glaube, dieses Mal, die ganze Saison schon, ich nehme jetzt mal die Vorbereitung einfach mit rein, sitzt da irgendwas recht tief in ihm und ich glaube, er versucht damit, immer wieder zu sagen, ich habe gewarnt und er hat wirklich sehr oft, sehr explizit gewarnt, schon auf der USA-Tour während der Vorbereitung, dass der Kader nicht optimal ist, dass das Spielermaterial nicht optimal ist, dass er dem Chief Executive, Ed Woodward, dem Transferverantwortlichen immer wieder Dinge zugeschoben, dass er ihm Spieler genannt habe, die er ganz gerne gehabt hätte. Auch ganz untypisch, dass am Deadline Day noch zwei Versuche für Innenverteidiger gemacht worden sind, die inzwischen wirklich aufgedeckt sind. Dass das so war und United holt sich da einen klassischen Korb, das ist aber glaube ich jetzt nicht so sehr bei Mourinho zu suchen, sondern das ist tatsächlich die Arbeit von Ed Woodward, der ist schon bekannt, es ist jetzt auch Van Raad, er hatte seine Probleme, auch David Moyes hatte seine Probleme mit dem, dass er wirklich da einen komischen Job manchmal macht und nicht ganz so stark ist, was die Kontakte und Überzeugungskraft betrifft. Also ein bisschen was ist sicherlich auch dabei, dass er mit dieser Art und Weise diese Pressekonferenz hat beenden können. Das hat ihm sicherlich nicht wehgetan und er kann das Echo ganz gut aushalten, aber dieses Jahr ist es glaube ich ein bisschen mehr als das übliche Taktieren, sondern ich glaube dieses Jahr ist er wirklich ein bisschen persönlich. Ich glaube, der weiß, dass da sein Ruf auf dem Spiel steht tatsächlich und dass das wirklich schiefgehen könnte.
Das weiß er glaube ich. Und wie nachhaltig sind denn die Probleme im United-Kader? Von außen betrachtet sieht das nicht so schlecht aus mit, wenn wir jetzt eben auf die Innenverteidigung zum Beispiel gucken, wo man noch gerne einen Spieler gehabt hätte, also Mourinho, dann sehe ich da einen Eric Baye, einen Victor Lindelöf, einen Phil Jones, einen Chris Smalling, Markus Rojo, da weiß ich jetzt grad nicht, wie der so drauf ist. Also das ist nicht die allerhöchste Spitzenklasse, aber ich hätte jetzt auch nicht gesagt, dass es unmöglich ist, damit eine stabile Verteidigung aufzustellen. Bin ich da zu schlecht auf dem aktuellen Stand bei den Spielern?
Also man muss mal eins sagen, Baye, Jones, Rojo, alle drei mit ganz großen Verletzungssorgen zu kämpfen. Immer wieder, andauernd. Und deshalb auch nie so richtig zu einsetzen gekommen. Deshalb ist in der vergangenen Saison Chris Smalling wieder zum Stammspieler geworden. Einer, der aber glaube ich ein bisschen zu steif ist, um wirklich auf höchstem Niveau gegenhalten zu können. Lindelöf hat ein paar gute Schritte gemacht in der abgelaufenen Saison, hat aber halt immer noch auch auf diesem hohen Niveau konstant Probleme, das per se dauernd abzurufen. Und bei Eric Bayi, ich hab die ersten beiden United-Spiele der Saison auch übertragen, gemeinsam mit Lindelöf, beide 24 Jahre alt, ich hab auch gesagt, das müsste doch eigentlich machbar sein. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass das irgendwelche Leute sind, die man aus der zweiten Liga geholt hat, sondern das sind hochtalentierte Leute, die auch in Teilen gezeigt haben, worum es geht. Aber am Ende des Tages trotzdem beide immer wieder Aussetzer drin haben. Das Problem ist, bei United muss man die Mannschaftsteile ganz häufig isoliert betrachten, weil es immer noch nicht gelungen ist, dass alle Mannschaftsteile autark für sich gute Leistungen bringen. Aber das Problem ist natürlich, dass Lindelöf und Bayi, die beiden, die jetzt im Moment da einfach spielen, halt auch häufig auch einfach Dinge vom Mittelfeld überlassen bekommen, die sie gar nicht mehr richtig lösen können. Und daran muss Mourinho am meisten arbeiten, dass das Mittelfeld, dass die Umkehrbewegung, das hat man, glaube ich, auch unter anderem in den Freit geholt, dass das halt besser funktioniert. Martic fehlt verletzungsbedingt, das darf man auch nicht vergessen. Also auch da ist wirklich große Verletzungsproblematik schon am Beginn der Saison. Kein Team hatte so viele Leute bei der Weltmeisterschaft so lange dabei, wie es die Mannschaft United hatte. Das darf man auch nicht vergessen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, die Balance, einfach das Verweben von Mannschaftsteilen, das wird extrem wichtig sein, da weiter dran zu arbeiten. Und es gibt noch eine weitere Position, wo ich wirklich große Bedenken habe, ist die Außenposition rechts vorne. Das spielt im Moment Juan Mata, der die meiste Zeit aber ins Zentrum zieht und oder zu wenig Tempo hat. Und das ist die Problematik der Einzige, der als theoretische Nummer 10 auflaufen könnte. Da hast du nämlich gar keinen. Du hast niemanden, der mit einem klugen Pass mal öffnen könnte. Also ein Mesut Özil zu Manchester United wäre von enormer Wichtigkeit. Von mir aus ein Spielertyp, wie Mesut Özil da reinzustellen, wäre von enormer Wichtigkeit. Du hast nämlich auf der linken Seite Alexis Sanchez, der die ganze Zeit nur auf eigene Rechnung tankt. Du hättest im Zweifeln einen Marcial oder einen Reshford, wo er versucht, die irgendwie so ein bisschen umzubauen, die aber glaube ich beide einfach Stürmer sind und dementsprechend funktioniert das ebenfalls nicht. Die sind eher auf dem eigenen Abschluss gepolt. Und jetzt lässt sich Romelu Lukaku, der Mittelstürmer, permanent auf die rechte Seite fallen und fehlt dann im Sturmzentrum. Also, hm, viele gleichartige Spieler, aber auf den Positionen, wo du den Missing Link bräuchtest, fehlt er mir. Und das ist meine Problematik, die ich sehe bei der Analyse im Kader von Manchester United. Klingt jetzt aber alles viel, viel schlechter als es ist, weil ich traue trotzdem Mourinho, wenn er ruhig arbeiten darf, zu, dass das trotzdem immer noch in Richtung eher 3 inzwischen geht als 2. Ich habe vor der Saison immer gesagt, ich habe die beiden Manchester Clubs in einer Riege bei Liverpool, muss ich noch gucken, wo ich hingehe. Die wären so die dritte Kraft für mich. Und danach kommt erst mal lange nichts. Und ich würde glaube ich im Moment eher Liverpool und United tauschen. Aber ich glaube schon, dass Mourinho das hinbekommt, dass die, es wird nie Samstag Nachmittag Entertainment werden, es wird es nie werden, aber dass die zumindest wieder Ergebnisse holen, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Wie gesagt, WM-Verletzungsgeschichten hatten jetzt auch einen Gegner in Tottenham. Und das Spiel muss man auch ehrlich sagen, war eines der besseren unter Mourinho überhaupt. Kann auch ganz anders laufen. Ist halt dann so, dann verlierst du halt mal 0-3 am Ende. Und wenn du 0-1 verloren hättest, wäre glaube ich auch vieles besser gelaufen. Ja, und der hat jetzt auch schon umgestellt in der Abwehr. Und das hat ja auch zum Teil funktioniert, so gesehen. Also da habe ich schon ein gewisses Vertrauen, dass das ergebnistechnisch irgendwann wieder sich konsolidiert.
Und dann ist ja aber das andere noch so ein bisschen die Artenweise, wie man die Ergebnisse einfängt. Und da hat Mourinho so ein bisschen Gegenparts bekommen durch Manchester City unter Guardiola, durch Liverpool unter Klopp. Hab ich den Eindruck, dass diese Grundsatzdiskussionen, also kann ein Mourinho-Fußball im Jahr 2018 noch erfolgreich sein, dass die ein bisschen lauter geworden sind. Wie wichtig, glaubst du, ist das tatsächlich, wenn wir jetzt mal aufs nähere Umfeld von United schauen, also auf die Fans und auf die Eigentümer?
Ja, auch die Legenden, die in England ja immer viel Redezeit erhalten, so à la Post Coast, die führen ja fast schon Privatfäden inzwischen mit Mourinho, weil die halt sagen, das ist super unattraktiv.
Und der Ferguson damals wurde ja nur brilliert, wie alle.
Genau, genau. Nur das hat man halt einfach nie gesehen, weil zu diesem Zeitpunkt einfach die Coverage der Premier League noch nicht so groß war. Aber Montagabendspiele und das Alex Ferguson, ich erinnere mich, Dunkel, die waren auch nicht gut, aber am Ende halt 1-0. Und deshalb war es immer in Ordnung. Und der Ferguson hat auch nie einen Hehl draus gemacht, erzählt er oder steht auch so in seinem Buch, dass es Spiele gab, wo du einfach in so einer 38-Spieltags-Saison schlicht und ergreifend punkten musst. Und das auch mit einer zweiten Mannschaft, die du halt vorher heiß gemacht hast. Also er hat ja auch erstaunlicherweise immer geschafft, dass die Solskjaers, die Chicharitos und so weiter fast schon froh waren, wenn sie dann mal in so einem Spiel gegen, ich meine, das jetzt gar nicht despektierlich, Wolverhampton oder so, dann einfach mal treffen durften. Ja, ich glaube schon, dass das irgendwann zum Problem wird. Mourinho unattraktiv, weil, und das ist das große Problem, sich Manchester United gerade, das heißt gerade, das ist schon passiert, längst passiert, hin zu einem stinknormalen Verein entwickelt haben. Und der Sir Alex Ferguson in dieser Zeit wäre Sir Alex aufgetreten in einer nicht zu lauten, aber sehr kautzigen Art und hätte gesagt, was wollt ihr eigentlich, wir sind Manchester United, guckt mal, wir haben 19 Titel oder 20 Titel zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Na gut, irgendwie tritt ja Mourinho ähnlich auf, wenn er sagt, hey, guck mal bitte, ich hab's hier schon dreimal geschafft und die anderen können alle gar nichts. Also jetzt mal bitte Füße stillhalten.
Richtig, genau. Aber mit natürlich einem anderen Background, weil er bei Manchester United noch nichts erreicht hat, aber wahnsinnig viel Geld ausgegeben hat. Und weil es noch dazu super unattraktiv ist und die anderen Mannschaften vorneweg erstmal super attraktiv spielen und besonders, dass Manchester City wegzieht, tut natürlich weh. Also gerade Manchester United weh, weil sie das Gefühl haben, sie verlieren die Außenaugen. Also das Ding ist bei Manchester United, ich würde denen in der vergangenen Saison einen gewaltigen Schritt nach vorne assistieren. Einen gewaltigen Schritt nach vorne im Vergleich zur ersten Mourinho-Saison und riesen, riesen Schritt im Vergleich zu den Van Gaal und vor allen Dingen Mois Saisons. Das Ding ist aber nur, Manchester City schwebt so sehr über allen Dingen und Manchester United wird sich zwangsweise immer damit vergleichen. Und deshalb verlieren sie auch ein bisschen an Ruhe. Und das ist das, was ich meine. Manchester United war früher in der eigenen Arroganz gefangen und das war aber gleichzeitig der größte Vorteil. Das war kein normaler Verein. Es gibt diverse Parts, wo Ferguson gesagt hat, ich habe einen Spieler angerufen, abgefragt Manchester United, ja nein. Und wenn er nicht sofort gesagt hat, ja, ja, ja, ich komme zu Fuß, dann nicht. Und diese Attitüde ist vollkommen flötengegangen. Die hinterfragen sich andauernd selbst, anstatt sie hergehen und sagen, ja, ja, spielt ihr mal Ballbesitzfußball, spielt ihr mal mit eurem Pressinggedönse. Wir haben unsere Idee. Gebt uns noch zwei Jahre und dann sind wir wieder da. Weil der Verein hat nach wie vor wirtschaftlich alles, was du brauchst. Der hat nach wie vor die Strahlkraft. Der hat nach wie vor mit Jose Mourinho jemanden, dem ich zutraue, dass er Ergebnisse holt. Er lebt im Moment so ein bisschen in der Vergangenheit, ja, aber das geht wahnsinnig schnell im Fußball, dass sich solche Dinge wieder verändern. Ich würde mir einfach nur wünschen, nicht Systemumstellen andauernd, sondern Stiefel durchziehen. Wird nicht attraktiv sein, aber Jose Mourinho hat in seiner Karriere, die lange genug andauernd gezeigt, Ergebnisse versteht er zu holen. Und das würde ich ihm auch mit diesem Kader zutrauen, der eben in Spitzen Fehler hat, keine Frage, aber gut genug ist und sicherlich auch zumindest knapp an Liverpool ranreicht. Die haben sich diesen Sommer klug verstärkt und haben wirklich genau das aufgefüllt, was ihnen noch gefehlt hat. Aber trotzdem so weit weg ist der Kader nicht. Und vielleicht sogar einen Ticken breiter als der von Liverpool. So gesehen. Also mein Votum für United weitermachen. Da, wo ihr jetzt seid und versuchen mit Geduld das Ganze einfach zu Ende zu bringen, um dann wieder anzugreifen. Das geht nämlich. Alles ist möglich.
Okay, es geht jetzt weiter für United beim FC Burnley. Dann Länderspielpause und dann dürfen sie nach Watford. Und wenn wir über Vereine sprechen, die in einer vermeintlich tiefen Krise stecken, schon nach drei Spieltagen, dann müssen wir auch über den FC Arsenal sprechen. Es ging los mit einem 0 zu 2 gegen Manchester City zu Hause, dann ein 2 zu 3 in London beim FC Chelsea und jetzt zu Hause gegen West Ham 3 zu 1, der erste Sieg in der Premier League. Aber natürlich haben alle ganz genau hingeguckt. Was macht Emery? Was macht er mit Özil? Und da gab es jetzt viele Diskussionen. Hol uns mal rein, was sind gerade so deiner Meinung nach die wichtigsten Themen beim FC Arsenal? Ist das Mesut Özil?
Das ist halt in Deutschland immer ein Thema, was ganz gerne genommen wird.
Genau deswegen habe ich dich gefragt. Dieses Gefühl hatte ich auch, aber ich kann es nicht beurteilen.
Es ist auch generell, diese ganze Erdogan-Bild-Thematik ist in England recht nüchtern aufgenommen worden. Also da wurde mal drüber gesprochen, aber in der Regel ist einfach nur noch die Rede von Ex International Mesut Özil. Das war dann auch irgendwie alles. Und Emery ist ja auch die ganze Zeit über, also er hat auch gesagt, selbst wenn er nicht gut in Form ist, ist es unsere Aufgabe, ihm zu helfen, weil er ein wichtiger Spieler ist. Und es wird in England eher darüber diskutiert. Also das ist gerade aktuell jetzt aufgeploppt, ob Ramsey und Özil miteinander gehen. Aber alle sind sich eigentlich ziemlich sicher, dass...
Also den Verein wechseln.
Nee, nee, also ob die beiden miteinander zusammen funktionieren können. Weil ja Ramseys Vertrag am Saisonende ausläuft. Der soll einen 5-Jahres-Deal vor sich liegen haben. Aber das Camp Ramsey überlegt wohl gerade so, ob sie sich nicht verändern, weil sie sich nicht sicher sind, welche Position Ramsey bei Arsenal bekommen würde. Und da wollen sie jetzt erst mal abwarten. Und dann ist natürlich die große Frage, die sehen ihn wohl eher so in... Also das Camp, Beraterschaft etc., die sehen ihn wohl eher so auf einer 8er- bis 10er-Position. Und so viele gibt's ja im System, MRIs nicht unbedingt. Und der hat sich relativ klar in Richtung Özil als 10er ausgesprochen. Und das ist jetzt im Moment ein kleines Thema geworden. Ich glaube gar nicht, dass es so sehr von Arsenal selbst kommt, sondern das machen gerade die Medien. Aber MRI hat sich ganz stark auch schon in der Vorbereitung dafür ausgesprochen. Und die Systematiken, die man kennt von ihm bisweilen, haben immer einen guten 10er gehabt und der hat meistens auch geglänzt. Das heißt, Özil ins System, MRI passt für mich eigentlich sehr gut. Er war am Wochenende krank, in Anführungszeichen. Da habe ich auch ein bisschen schmunzeln müssen, tatsächlich als ich das gelesen habe, weil das war meistens in den letzten Jahren so ein Kot dafür, wenn er krank war oder Rücken hatte, dann war es meistens ein Kot dafür, dass er einfach müde war. Das hat man dann hinterher auch immer zugegeben. Und jetzt wurde da draußen Streit gemacht mit Una Emery, die ihn aber sofort dementiert hat. Und dann muss ich auch ehrlich sagen, dann muss ich erstmal auch den Aussagen Emerys glauben und jetzt nicht da irgendwie versuchen, nur weil es gerade Unwoke ist, Mesut Özil irgendwas anzudichten, dass ich da mitmache. Nee, also das ist kein großes Thema. Und ich bin ziemlich sicher, der wird am nächsten Spieltag auch wieder spielen. Der wird auch wieder ordentliche Leistungen bringen. Einzig, was ich so als kleines Problem sehe, wenn du dein Defensivkonstrukt, und das ist ja neu bei Arsenal, komplettes Pressing, endlich auch im Jahr 2018 bei Arsenal angekommen, dass du da mit Mesut Özil einen zentralen Spieler hast in diesem Pressing, also als erster Angreifer, das wird problematisch. Und das finde ich auch gar nicht so gut, dass Özil da mitmachen muss, geht halt aber in diesem System nicht anders. Das wird problematisch, aber ansonsten alles im Soll, was auch seine Entwicklung mit Arsenal 18, 19 betrifft, alles im Soll und kein großes Thema.
Und wie ist da so die Gemengelage, wenn wir auf das Stichwort Erwartungsmanagement gucken? Also, FC Arsenal, wir alle haben mitbekommen, diese wahnsinnig großen Fußstapfen von Arsene Wenger, aber auch schon auf dem absteigenden Ast in den letzten Spielzeiten. Was glaubst du, wie geduldig ist man mit Emery, mit der Mannschaft? Was muss am Ende dieser Saison für den FC Arsenal herausbringen, dass man im Umfeld, bei den Eigentümern, bei den Fans, in den Medien halbwegs gelassen mit dieser Spielzeit umgeht und sagt, ja, das war jetzt unsere Umbruchssaison, jetzt geht's dann den nächsten Schritt weiter?
Ich versuche, die dann immer zu überreden und ihnen zu sagen, schau bitte nicht so sehr auf den Platz, sondern mehr auf die Entwicklung. Alles in allem, die sind natürlich trotzdem irgendwie erfolgsverwöhnt, aber alles in allem ist die Erwartungshaltung schon realistisch und das ist zum Beispiel ein wesentlicher Unterschied zur Übernahme Mois nach Sir Alex bei Manchester United und jetzt Emery nach Wenger bei Arsenal. Dass die schon verstehen, ja, wir haben Mannschaftsteile, die sehr gut sind, das ist die Offensive, und wir haben Mannschaftsteile, die existent sind, das ist die Defensive und die, glaube ich, verstehen schon auch, dass die Altersstruktur nicht hundertprozentig ganz glücklich ist und die verstehen vor allen Dingen, und das haben sie in den ersten beiden Spielen gelernt, ganz schwieriges Auftragsprogramm, dass dieses System Emery komplett konträr zu dem Wengers ist und dementsprechend einfach, dass eine Zeit lang dauern wird, bis dass die Spieler drin haben werden in sich. Und haben dann einfach Hoffnung, dass es dann vielleicht so in Richtung Europa liegt. Emery soll ja etwas davon verstehen, diese zu gewinnen, vielleicht da, was es zu holen gibt. Nee, aber alles in allem, glaube ich schon, das Umfeld, da muss man jetzt mal abwarten, wie es tatsächlich der Verein sieht, weil da hat sich ja was geändert. Sten Kroenke, der seinen Stand hat übernommen, hat komplett die Hauptanteilschaft sich geholt, erst vor kurzem. Und da muss man jetzt mal abwarten, der soll wiederum mit Gassides, dem neuen starken Mann nach Wengers Abgang, bei Arsenal nicht sehr gut können. Im Gegenteil, Gassides soll sich sogar überlegen, in Richtung AC Mailand zu gehen, hat aber eine Ausstiegsklausel, die ihm das jetzt erstmal nicht möglich macht.
Welche Funktion hat der bei Arsenal gerade?
Das ist sozusagen der Chief Executive, also Edward Watts, counterpart von Manchester United. Das heißt, hat sozusagen alle Fäden erstmal in der Hand verteilt, die dann wiederum auf den zwischen neu installierten Sportdirektor Sanlehi, dann Mislintat, der für Scouting, Recruitment zuständig ist und eben dann den Trainer Una Emery, um jetzt mal die drei größten zu nennen. Da gibt es dann auch noch ein paar andere, die haben sich auch noch mal im rechtlichen oder Werbungsraum neue Leute geholt. Also das ist wirklich ein ganz neues Board da zusammengestellt bei Arsenal. Aber da muss man jetzt erstmal tatsächlich abwarten. Die Fans haben ein bisschen Angst gehabt, nachdem Kroenke übernommen hat, weil die wissen, dass er sich eigentlich gar nicht so richtig kümmert um den Verein. Er ist in der Regel in den USA und das Verein liegt nicht unbedingt Fußball sachverständig. Kann sein, dass es alles wesentlich ins-transparenter wird. Das ist wohl die Idee, dass er sich einfach nicht mehr mit den Fans auseinandersetzen muss, bevor er Entscheidungen trifft. Deswegen wollte er noch die fehlenden Anteile haben und dass er einfach dann sozusagen Arsenal in Richtung Weltunternehmen aufbaut, dass er vollkommen dann an Romantik verliert. Ich glaube schon, dass auch die Zeiten für Arsenal-Fans gekommen sind, denen ihnen klar sein muss. Das wird jetzt auch ein Stück weit zu einem normalen Verein und das wird nichts mehr zu tun haben mit dem, was unter Wenger da war. Auf der einen Seite, sportlich finden sie das gut. Auf der anderen Seite, was den romantischen Teil der Veranstaltungen betrifft, glaube ich, werden sie das lernen, schlecht zu finden. Aber da mag ich noch gar nichts prognostizieren. Auch da gilt für mich, sowohl MRE habe ich immer gesagt, lass den jetzt erstmal arbeiten. Das Auftragsprogramm war super schwer mit City und Chelsea. Wenn es bloß läuft, hast du null Punkte. Genauso ist es gekommen. Jetzt haben sie sich gegen West Ham verbessert, ohne mich überzeugt zu haben. So richtig. Aber es ist weder alles schlecht noch alles gut, sondern es ist einfach alles gerade im Flux. Und das ist völlig in Ordnung zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Saison. Ich würde diese Saison tatsächlich als Übergangs-Saison nehmen. Vielleicht gibt es sogar noch eine zweite mit dazu, wo dann langsam einfach weiter Dinge eingewoben werden, die Emery davor hat. Jetzt haben sie ein ganz gutes Programm, was ansteht. Da werden sie ein paar Punkte holen. Und irgendwas von Platz 5, wenn es ganz ideal läuft, ist Platz 8, 9 ist für mich denkbar.
Also geht es dann weiter in Cardiff und nach der Länderspielpause dann in Newcastle. Jetzt, wenn wir aber schon über so Menschen sprechen, der Namen mir nicht gleich geläufig waren, hätte ich eine generelle Frage an dich, Uli. Ich hatte das so abgespeichert, dass es in der Premier League noch häufig so war, zu den großen Zeiten von Ferguson zum Beispiel, dass der Trainer gleichzeitig auch Manager war und auch die Transfers und so weiter eingefädelt hat. Hat sich das jetzt verändert zu mehr solchen Strukturen, wie du es jetzt genannt hast, weil es hört sich jetzt ja eher so an, sowohl bei United als auch bei Arsenal, bei City, weiß man auch, dass es ähnlich ist, dass der Trainer zwar immer noch eine große Rolle spielt bei Transfers, aber dass das eigentliche Handling und das Abwicklen von Transfers jetzt doch dann von anderen Personen übernommen wird.
Ja, also der ausführende Teil, der ist schon immer auch von Geschäftsleuten dann gemacht worden, das war auch bei Alex Ferguson, David Gill, der da einen Riesensjob gemacht hat, aber inzwischen mit Sportdirektor setzt sich schon mehrheitlich durch. Das liegt vor allen Dingen daran, dass wahnsinnig viele Nicht-Insel-Manager da sind und die bringen diese Idee erst mal mit, sehen dann, dass das entlastend ist und es geht schon mehrheitlich dazu über, dass der Trainer wirklich nur noch Trainer ist oder in England ganz oft dann nicht unbedingt nur Trainer, sondern eher Supervisor auf dem Trainingsplatz. Das heißt, er hat dann noch mal seine Coaching-Stuff. Auch die werden immer größer in England. Aber ja, das ist schon auch in England so zu beobachten, dass man sich da ein bisschen öffnet und einfach, ja, das ist ja auch nur sinnvoll, einfach Expertisen-Departements aufbaut und halt eben einem sagt, Mislintat ist jemand, der natürlich vernetzt ist, der versteht es einfach auch, Spieler hochzurechnen mit dem Potenzial. Und das kann ja jemand, der in der täglichen Arbeit gefangen ist, gar nicht so unbedingt machen kann, hat auch gar nicht die Erfahrung damit. Es ist also nur sinnvoll, dass Emery diesen Part abgibt. Und Sanli wiederum selbst ist dann für die Systematik, für die Eingliederung auch von Jugendspielern tätig. Und alles, was noch so drum herum geschieht. Also es ist für mich nur sinnvoll und es wird auch weiter Einzug finden in England.
Okay, interessant, danke dir. Und jetzt kommen wir zu einem unerwarteten Thema, ein bisschen wie der unerwartete Einstieg beim Brennerpass. Ich habe im hervorragenden Podcast Doppel 6, das sind die großen zwei, Doppel 6 und Brennerpass, habe ich gehört, was bei Wolverhampton Wanderers so los ist. Das fand ich ganz interessant. Die haben ja jetzt einen portugiesischen Trainer mit Nuno Espirito Santo. Und wie durch ein Wunder, wenn ich mir so die Transfers angucke, sehr, sehr viel Südeuropäisches mit dabei. Also Adama Traoré, ein Spanier, Diogo Rota, ein Portugiese von Atletico. Und da kannst du so durchgehen, Juan Motinho spielt jetzt bei den Wanderers, Rui Patricio. Und ich habe jetzt noch gar nicht alle davon ausgezählt. Von außen betrachtet sieht das so aus, als ob man da einen gewissen portugiesisch-spanischen Einfluss ausmachen könnte.
Es sagt dir Choche Mendez etwas. Der Berater, Gottfather dieser Welt. Wirden Anteile in diesem Verein nachgesagt. Also Nuno Espirito Santo gehört ihm. Es ist in seiner Agentur und selbstverständlich auch Motinho, auch Patricio, auch Jota, auch Elda Costa. Ach, was? Und was, wenn nicht alles haben. Die EFL, also die English Football League, sozusagen die Dachorganisation, die liegen zwei bis vier unter ihrem Dach, die sind immer noch am Ermitteln, ob das rechtens ist, was er da macht. Das gibt einen Deal mehr oder weniger zwischen dem chinesischen Owner von Wolverhampton und Jorge Mendes, der bedeutet, du kannst hier deine Spieler parken, aber du musst sie mir auch bringen. Eine Anlaufstelle, wo die unter deinem Trainer sich genau so entwickeln, wie du das möchtest. Und das ist natürlich, also es gibt noch kein Regularium, dass das verbietet, aber moralisch zumindest schon mal ein bisschen fragwürdig, wenn man sich überlegt, na gut, dann hol ich mir jetzt als Berater einfach 12 Leute zusammen und mach eine eigene Mannschaft.
Das ist ja quasi der Anti-Heidel, der da gemacht wird.
Richtig, genau, exakt. Und Heidel würde ich jetzt eher in die etwas romantischere Ecke stellen. Und Mendes, Wolverhampton, ist natürlich genau das Gegenteil davon. Also man kann das dann schon hinterfragen. Nochmal, ich muss das ganz deutlich machen, es ist nichts geklärt. Es ist rein rechtlich alles okay, was da passiert. Zumindest ist das aktuell Stand der Dinge. Die EFL ist nach wie vor hinten nach. Es gibt einige Trainer der zweiten englischen Liga im Besonderen, die haben die ja dominiert letzte Saison, logischerweise. Mit Spielern wie Ruben Neves und Co. ist es easy. Die von Wettbewerbsverzerrung sprechen und sagen, es ist echt unfair, was da gerade passiert. Als normaler Zweitligist würdest du dergleichen nie bekommen. Wenn man das da ist und auch einen schönen Sitz im Stadion genießt, dann geht das schon eher. Natürlich macht er sich seine Taschen voll und gleichzeitig steigert er den Wert seiner Spieler. Das kann jeder für sich selbst hochrechnen, dass das durchaus sinnvoll ist aus seiner Warte heraus. Dass auch der Verein das vielleicht gut findet, aber dass die anderen das nicht so gut finden. Aber das ist der Plot dahinter. Und deswegen ist Wolverhampton auch kein ganz normaler Aufsteiger. Und deswegen bin ich auch gar nicht so überrascht, dass die sich jetzt gar nicht so schlecht machen in den ersten Spieltagen, weil das ist eine halbe portugiesische Nationalmannschaft erweitert. Ich glaube, Adama kann man sogar rausnehmen aus der Geschichte, weil der ist tatsächlich wirklich einfach nur dahin. Dann wollten sie auch gar nicht mehr unbedingt bei Middlesbrough, weil er sehr viel dribbelt, aber nicht immer ganz effizient ist. Aber die anderen, also besonders die Portugiesen, das ist eine reine Mendes-Geschichte, der halt als Berater ja schon Einfluss genießt und gesagt hat, rüberhemden wäre doch cool.
Weißt du, was ich mir wünschen würde, wenn wir hier in Deutschland über 50 plus einsprechen, würde ich auch gerne solche Beispiele mal ranziehen, weil das ist einfach nur möglich, weil ein Investor mit einem anderen Typen einen Deal macht und wenn jetzt die Liga da nichts gegen unternehmen kann, und so auf dem Papier ist das ja erst mal legitim, können sie ja erst mal machen, was sie wollen, dann kannst du dagegen nichts verändern. Und es kann eben sein, dass das den Charakter von Wolverhampton oder den spielerisch-hatschen Charakter schon verändert. Aber auch als Verein kann das ja das komplette Ding einmal auf eine andere Farbe drehen. Also, Wahnsinn. Man muss es nicht verteufeln, aber ich würde es gerne mitdiskutieren, wenn wir über 50 plus 1 sprechen.
Ja, also ich glaube, du hast gerade Heidel genannt, mach das mal bei Schalke. Wohlbehemden ist ein traditioneller englischer Verein. Wirklich, es gibt ganz viele eingesessene Engländer. Wir haben ja, also DAZN ist ja ein englischer Mutterunternehmen und wir arbeiten ganz viel mit Engländern zusammen. Und ganz viele von den Technikern, die dort vor Ort sind, sagen immer, wo ist my babies, go on und so. Also, die sind wirklich mit denen. Das ist ja gar nicht mehr das Gleiche. Das ist ja eine portugiesische Nationalmannschaft. Das soll zum Weltverein werden, war auch eines der ersten Clubs, der 2-Liga-Spiele nach China vermarktet hat, auf eigene Faust mit diesem neuen Besitzer. Der natürlich auch viel reinbuttert, das ist das Gute. Und ich bin jetzt lang genug in England, um zu wissen, na ja, Christian Heidel-Romantik wird es halt nicht mehr geben. Deshalb finde ich das erstmal, das ist ein Farbtupfer in der Liga und die spielen halt guten Fußball. So habe ich mir das selbst schon verkauft. Obwohl ich natürlich, wenn ich dahinter denke, halt sag, na ja, also komm. Aber das ist jetzt erstmal das Gute. Aber wenn ich Wolverhampton Fan wäre und Traditionalist wäre, würde ich auch sagen, na ja, also, ob ich das jetzt so brauche. Also ein paar sind ja ganz nett und so drei Spieler davon sind ja in Ordnung. Aber jetzt nimmt es halt langsam überhand.
Ja, so ist es. Lass noch ganz kurz auf die Top-Clubs gucken. Wir haben jetzt nicht die Zeit, das nur um auf jeden im Detail anzugehen, aber es wird ja noch weitere solche Folgen geben im Verlaufe dieser Saison. Wenn ich dir jetzt sagen würde, ich möchte ein Spiel schauen, entweder vom FC Liverpool, von den Spurs, von Chelsea oder von City, wen sollte ich mir angucken, um den aktuell besten Fußball in der Premier League zu sehen? Oder den interessantesten Fußball?
Nee, war schwierig. Ich würde momentan immer sagen, Chelsea sollte man immer gucken, weil das gerade sehr Interessante ist, was sich von Spiel zu Spiel noch mal tut und verändert. Das ist jetzt aber einfach nur so, wenn man die Schablone von letzter Saison danebenlegt, Konter hatte und jetzt Zari, dann ist es schon ganz spannend, was da gerade passiert auf dem Feld. Ist aber jetzt gar nicht mehr so attraktiv, liegt aber auch daran, dass die Gegner häufig jetzt nicht so gut waren und entsprechend war es. Also gegen Jukka, das war schon schwierig. Also bei Liverpool, ich würde die Entscheidung zwischen Liverpool und City machen und ich glaube, es wird sogar momentan eher Richtung Liverpool gehen. Auch mit den benannten Gründen, dass das mit Cater gerade sehr spannend ist und dass mir mehr Spaß macht, gerade Unterschiede zur letzten Saison rauszufiltern. Bei City weiß ich, was ich habe. Das ist natürlich immer ziemlich gut.
Das ist sich aber auch immer sehr ähnlich. Kurzpass, Kurzpass, Kurzpass, Kurzpass, Kurzpass, Vertikalpass, Sprint, Ablagebund.
Da ist Liverpool vermutlich schon, da bewegt sich fast noch ein bisschen mehr. Und vor allen Dingen bin ich halt dann gespannt, die spielen im Moment noch zu Null. Das wird sich aber irgendwann verändern. Und da bin ich dann auch sehr gespannt, wie das dann läuft. Also wie der Charakter der Mannschaft sich dann mit den Zugängen verändert und so. Also ein paar spannende Projekte im Moment da im Laufen. Auf hohem Niveau und auch auf niedrigem Niveau, also auch unten in der Tabelle ein paar ganz spannende Projekte gerade in der Premier League.
Absolut. Dann sag uns noch ein spannendes Projekt aus der unteren Hälfte der Tabelle. Dann haben wir hier einen Rundumblick gehabt in dieser Folge.
Da gucke ich wirklich jedes Spiel, weil... Genau. Übrigens Andre Schürrle. Also ich freue mich wirklich. Ich glaube, das könnte ein projizierter 10-Tore-Mann werden in der Saison. Und dann wäre das eine riesen, riesen Rückkehr nach England für ihn. Ne Fulham hat mit Jokanovic einen Trainer, der sieht zwar aus wie ein Serienmörder, weil der bewegt sich einfach nicht in seinem Gesicht. Der sieht immer gleich aus. Und auch beim Aufstieg in den Playoffs, der hoch dramatisch war, du siehst ihn einfach nicht lachen. Aber lässt einen super offensiven Fußball spielen. Und vor allen Dingen mit schönen Positionswechseln, mit guten, cleveren Bällen, die er da geben lässt, haben sich unglaublich gut verstärkt. Also für einen Aufsteiger vollkommen irre. Haben aber am Deadline-Day noch mal 5 Spieler geholt. Und es wird noch ein bisschen dauern, bis die da wirklich alle eingearbeitet sind. Aber hatten schon einen starken 2. Liga-Kader, guten Fußballern und haben ein unglaubliches Stadion. Also Craven Cottage ist der Hammer. Und da gucke ich einfach immer hin, weil das könnte auch in Richtung einstellig gehen. Vermutlich noch nicht in dieser Spielzeit. Aber das ist auch so ein Projekt, das könnte richtig gut werden. Die haben sich unter Jokanovic straight zu einem attraktiven und erfolgreichen Team entwickelt. Meistens immer in der 2. Saisonhälfte vor allen Dingen. Die haben immer Startschwierigkeiten gehabt und sind dann in der 2. Hälfte nochmal so richtig gekommen. Und wenn das auch in der Premier League passiert, dann ist das echt... Da gucke ich echt immer hin. Also die Spiele gucke ich auch.
Hab leider noch keins machen dürfen.
Das kommt hoffentlich noch, aber die schau ich immer.
Ach, Mensch, Uli, du hast es wieder geschafft, dass man richtig Bock auf die Premier League hat. Und zwar nicht nur auf die großen Clubs. Und das, finde ich, ist immer das Besondere dann noch. Uli, ich danke dir mal wieder. Das hat sehr, sehr großen Spaß gemacht. Ja, ich danke dir. Und man kann dir folgen auf Twitter, etUliHebel heißt er dort. Man kann ihn hören auf TheZone als Kommentator. Das ist ja sowieso klar. Und dann danke ich auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war mal wieder ein kleiner Blick in die europäischen Top-League. Machen wir jetzt wieder regelmäßiger im Rasenfunk. In welcher Frequenz will ich mich hier noch nicht festlegen. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bewertet uns bei iTunes. Und schaltet auch das nächste Mal wieder ein. Ciao.